alrighty folks it's been an absolutely
insane year businesses small and large
have had to adjust to the many changes
brought on by the kova 19 pandemic
industries across the globe have shut
down many people have lost their jobs
the pandemic has taken a serious toll on
the economy with the help
of our friends at giant partners we're
going to explore some of the data
giant partners is america's number one
data-driven marketing company they took
an
integral role in putting together this
video so
here's the reality most of us identify
covered with the negatives because there
have been tons of negatives particularly
in the world of
business but there are a few positives
so let's talk a little bit about the
positive side of how business adapted
this is a beautiful thing about
capitalism
it tends to adapt but covet obviously
changed the world of the restaurant
industry delivery apps like doordash and
postmates they've got a ton of momentum
due to covid19
if outgrown restaurants own in-house
delivery systems that's created a lot of
employment for people
who needed jobs particularly temporary
jobs we've also seen an expanded drive
through lines for fast food with
multiple lanes a lot of people taking
orders you've seen a rise in contactless
payments and qr code menus which is
really convenient and it's great
technology
you've seen online ordering via website
and apps boosting demand for companies
like doordash
there are 832 000 jobs in the industry
nationally about 4 800 new businesses
were added
in 2020. now we'll get to the downsides
in just one second in the restaurant
industry
meanwhile travel industry is known for
having restrictive policies in terms of
cancellations and trip changes
experts think this is over which
actually is great how many times have
you bought a flight
and then for some odd reason you have to
cancel and then it's like well we're
just going to charge you for the flight
anyway
no more of that telehealth and
telemedicine has grown tremendously
we've taken advantage of this
my wife is serving patients via
telehealth and telemedicine
and by the way doctors have been waiting
for this for a long time it took state
licensing agencies to actually let this
go
because of the pandemic and now they do
and that's great because now
patients can get diagnoses or
prescriptions over a zoom call or phone
call
that's not going to change moving
forward because that's great service
it's a lot better than going and waiting
in a waiting room
for an hour before meeting with a doctor
for five minutes mental health services
are now available online through zoom
sessions with therapists which is
fantastic
hospital preparedness is more important
than ever hospitals are going to
continue to stockpile
ppe that's personal protective equipment
and emergency equipment and other
products that patients need
gun sales skyrocketed in 2020 compared
to 2019. according to statista by august
of 2020 firearm sales grew
by 57.8 compared to the previous year
around 1.8 million handguns were sold in
the united states
you could see a rise in the home office
industry i think there are a lot of
people who have been working from home
who are just going to continue
working from home do companies really
want to spend literally millions of
dollars on overhead when everybody can
do the same job
from their house you could see a rise in
the number of jobs that are that are
capable of being done
via the internet that's going to require
a new set of skills that people can
train for and that's going to require a
difference in how we educate kids in
high school and college particularly
obviously that also means that when it
comes to commercial real estate you
could see commercial real estate take a
hit for quite
a while it's one thing to open a retail
store for clothing
when people go back to the malls it is
quite another thing to lease
tens of thousands of feet of office
space when you have an industry that can
basically
be delegated to people working at home
now before we continue i want to talk to
you about giant partners they're not
only
a one-stop shop for all your advertising
needs as i've said before they helped us
gather a lot of the data and stats for
this video every company
strives to have unique values and a long
lasting impact it's time to position
your company
as an industry leader create buzz
attract new customers generate
consistent revenue
giant partners is here to help you do
this and we built daily wire we focused
an awful lot
on marketing and data it's what we
needed marketing and data
if you want your business to be
successful it's got to be data driven
luck is not a business plan as i very
often say well
this is where giant partners comes in
giant partners is america's number one
data-driven marketing agency
giant partners operates in the business
to business space offering a variety of
business marketing solutions like
database marketing brand development web
design seo lead generation digital
marketing services
as well as ad placement that's just to
name a few of their services
whether you own a small family business
or handle millions in revenue every year
giant partners can help you get to the
next level their marketing strategies
are research driven they are equipped
with 20 years of data experience
don't take my word for it their largest
customers include bmw nationwide ohio
state university 3m
and ethan allen so head on over to
giantpartners.com to get your business
set up today alrighty now we get to the
negatives there are lots and lots of
negatives lockdowns in 2020 decreased
new business creation an estimated 82
this is in stark contrast what you will
hear from media outlets that try to
rose in butterfly 2020. in 2019 in a
thriving economy there were 933
821 new businesses created with sales
this accounted for
1.66 million new jobs in 2020 with the
government locking everybody down there
were only 171
423 new businesses created with sales
this accounted
for only 315 327
new jobs this reduction obviously leads
to a massive loss in job creation
lockdowns in 2020 decreased new job
creation by an estimated 1.3
million jobs that stat is on top of the
9.5 million jobs that have been
reportedly lost
since february 2020. the opportunity
cost of the lockdowns can be simply
stated
an estimated 762 398 companies
with 1 million 345 607 new jobs
that should have been created in 2020
never happened
let's dive into some of these companies
that have been hammered by the pandemic
lots of different aspects of the
entertainment industry have been
affected in tremendous ways like
obviously movie theaters closed
concerts shut down athletic games shut
down
consumers have had to turn to other
mediums to consume both visual
and audio content theme parks as we
adjust their entertainment experience to
fit the safety and sanitation guidelines
of the cdc and florida's great
so disney world here has been open in
california you couldn't even open up
disneyland when it comes to restaurants
bars and clubs you can see the utter
devastating effect of this pandemic and
particularly the shutdown orders
on this entire industry the labor force
stats from the current population survey
show
within food services and drinking places
industry the unemployment rate increased
from 6.2 percent in january of 2020
before the pandemic to 14.4
in january of 2021. gyms have been just
devastated to date more than 15 billion
dollars in revenue has been lost in gyms
and personal care
according to a club intel study u.s
fitness center still in business
projected a 37 percent decline in
revenue in 2020
relative to 2019. how about
entertainment but within the arts
entertainment and recreation industry
the unemployment rate increased this is
unbelievable from 4.7
in january 2020 to 19.1 percent
in january 2021 that's why you've seen
the stock of amc take this massive
massive hit
according to statista the film industry
worldwide experienced a 7
billion loss in revenue as of mid-march
2020 and a 10 billion
loss in revenue as of the end of may
2020. travel and hospitality has been
absolutely shellacked within the
accommodations industry the unemployment
rate increased from just 6.4
in january 2020 to 23.1
in january 2021. according to the u.s
travel association
travel spending totaled about 679
billion dollars in 2020. that is a 42
annual decline this 500 billion dollar
decline from 2019.
since the beginning of march through the
end of 2020 the pandemic had resulted in
492 billion dollars in cumulative losses
for the us travel economy that equates
to a daily loss of 1.6 billion dollars
every day
for the past 10 months how about in the
car industry well within the
transportation and warehouse industry
the unemployment rate jumped from 3.4
in january 2020 to 9 in january 2021
the estimated reduction in auto demand
following the coveted pandemic as of
october 2020. western europe experienced
a reduction of 3.84
million in terms of its vehicle demand
north america experienced
a reduction of 2.52 million cars in
terms of vehicle demand
these industries are going to be
devastated probably forever there are
adjustments that have had to take place
particularly in the travel industry it's
gonna be a while before travel recovers
you're gonna have to see airlines bailed
out when it comes to the car industry
you might have to see car manufacturers
looking for bailouts from governments
in terms of entertainment are the
theaters ever gonna come back i mean
that is a serious question a lot of
people have moved to streaming services
and they may never go back to theaters
ever ever again not just because they're
afraid but they've gotten used to
watching streaming entertainment from
their couches and is that going to have
an impact
on how these particular movies get
funded movies and tv shows
are we done with the day of 300 million
dollar movies in the end
however i think that some of these
changes that we have seen
are going to end up being rather
temporary we're going to boom after this
people have been pent up
for a year people cannot wait to go out
go to ball games go to theaters
get back to regular life i think people
are going to travel more than they ever
have
in the aftermath of kovac 19 as
countries begin to open their borders
again
there's gonna be a lot of international
travel you've already seen travel uptick
in the united states in pretty
tremendous ways
if another pandemic were to happen again
today i think that governments would be
very keen on shutdowns early which when
it comes to travel is probably
not a bad idea certainly there's gonna
be a lot of support for
backing preparedness i don't think we're
ever gonna have a ppe shortage again and
i think there's gonna be a lot of focus
on social distancing
on mask wearing but maybe not on
lockdowns because the reality is
that those lockdowns were not
tremendously helpful in places like new
york they weren't helpful in places
like california i think that we could
learn the wrong lessons from this
pandemic i'm hopeful that we will learn
the right lessons from this pandemic
which is that
we have to take into account all of the
factors when we make public policy and
if we're going to shut things down you
have to do it right away and then you
have to get out of lockdown as soon as
humanly possible afterward
we also got used to the lockdown and
that's a real problem in terms of our
liberty
getting used to the government telling
you to stay in your house and then stay
there even past the point of riskiness
which is what is currently happening
you know have members of the government
telling you you can't go back to regular
life even if you're vaccinated
don't let your mentality change if your
mentality changes then they have robbed
you of your freedom even after the
pandemic
so go back to normal let's all get back
to normal these industries need you to
get back to normal
and i think we are going to get back to
normal i think you're going to see
demand i think that you're going to see
a tremendous amount of innovation and i
think that maybe some of the
improvements that came along will stick
hopefully a lot of the losses that these
industries experienced
will go away as we move forward from
this terrible pandemic